[Music]
Ross when did the game turn yesterday in
New England when the Steelers got
stuffed on the goal line yeah after we
thought jesse james scored a touchdown
the tight end for the steelers and on
review they marked the ball at the half
yard line he was rather than doing a
quarterback sneak with big been handed
off to be Angela Williams he lost a good
yard and a half they had to settle for a
field goal there and just kind of got
the sense the way Brady was playing in
the way the Steelers defense was playing
that if the fuels are going to have a
chance they're going to match him score
for score settling for a fuel pool there
felt like you know it was taking a step
closer to losing for Pittsburgh which
Pittsburgh in their own heads in the red
zone if you look at what they did or
didn't do against Kansas City and then
with New England you can't you can't win
games against New England if if you're
kicking field goals no I don't
understand why they don't run the ball
more especially given their receiver
issues and how many times they gotta
throw the ball to sammie coates third
and one you're throwing a bomb to a guy
that catches the borrower twenty-five
percent of the time I mean it's they
really really missed martavis Bryant and
knowing that they don't have them then
you got to run the ball more than they
did I don't know why they did that but
then again Dan I don't know why I did a
lot of things it i mean hit a three-man
rush most of the game anybody that's
ever watched the Patriots and Brady lose
a playoff game knows you have to hit
them look at the giant look at the
Broncos you have to hit them instead i'm
watching bud Dupree and James Harrison
drop back into coverage more than half
the time three-man rush it's like the
game plan ban or it's the hope that the
greatest quarterback of all time has a
bad day I mean that's not a plan well
Mike Conlon said that they couldn't get
to Brady but I thought you had to sell
you have to sell out at some point and
say if we don't get to him then then
we're dying we're going to die a quick
death here
yes he they're gonna be a quick death or
a slow death and I haven't died yet but
I'd rather have a quick death I don't
want to slow test so at least come with
you know four or five guys they puts one
time they got picked up and that's when
Brady had like five seconds so that
first touchdown pass to Hogan and the
most think they got gun-shy at that
point I asked Tom and a half time I
somebody gonna pressure more he said
maybe but no matter what the call is we
gotta execute better our young guys are
playing a little scatterbrained is what
he told me and it showed I mean already
burns that they had a rough rough day I
expected a lot more from the sealers Dan
that was really disappointing you've got
a chance to speak to Brady postgame I
did it yeah it was cool like we were
teammates ten years ago and now I'm
interviewing them as you go to his
record seven Super Bowl which is just
ridiculous did he recognize you run yeah
yeah he said hey wait for the compound
to me he said hey Ross are you imagine
good former Patriot you know that I
didn't notice I defense or less than one
he's the only guy that at the end of the
interview all year said thanks Ross
usually guys that don't know me or never
the only guys still playing for my play
but it was actually like I mean dad you
know I was a senator 405 and 06 I was
one with backup center so Tom and I had
a very intimate relationship in that way
as the quarterback center exchange did
he recognize you only when you bent over
to do the interview no I could not heavy
right away but very funny and you you're
the one that brought it to the nation's
attention that that young lady was a
great beard sugar best i've ever seen
and i was in a fraternity in college I
thought Chris hoagie Haven ER from
Central Park West was the best beer
chugger I'd ever seen when I was in
college Brady put him to shame it's
really know it sounds funny when you say
it then but the guy has every positive
male quality known him in like I was
almost mad that he was that good of a
charger because I'm say everything and
this is just not fair like why is God
not spreading the world a little bit
more he's Ross Tucker
former Patriot NFL lineman working for
Westwood one on the side lunge yesterday
with the Patriots in the Steelers the
falcon game i don't know how much you
got to watch that but watching that it
feels like the difference is the defense
is now reputable we knew the offense was
great but was I mean how formidable is
Atlanta now they're very legit I think
if you look at the last two drafts
especially on defense it's been
unbelievable mean Scott Pioli took over
the trash two years ago Jalen Collins
vic beasley Dion Jones key on O'Neill
DeAndre gamble it's been unbelievable
which is why I by the way Dan if I'm the
niners I am doing everything in my power
to bring Kyle Shanahan and scapula both
those guys to my team that would be a
home run and then eventually I think
people are finally realizing what we're
seeing here which is this is greatest
show on turf stuff I mean not five yards
per play ever Matt Ryan number one yards
per attempt ever and now that they've
actually one they're going to Superbowl
I think over the next two weeks they'll
probably finally get the credit they
deserve for being one of all time great
offenses but is offense or defense going
to win the super bowl I think it's going
to be a high scoring game I mean as good
as they've played I currently envision
them holding Brady in the Patriots to
less than 24 so I think I probably 2724
it is the score of the game one way or
the other and probably the higher
scoring it gets the better for the
Falcons I just show the strength of the
Patriots defense is that secondary
McCourty Malcolm Butler Logan Ryan had a
great year I don't know that the Falcons
are going to be able to put up 35 38
especially with you know bello checks
and Patricia having that much time to
breathe oh I think it'll be a great game
I think yesterday was proved in that's
two best teams one and the true team
that deserve to be there will be at the
shame of it though is the Cowboys in the
Chiefs would have given us much better
games yesterday but that's obviously not
how it played out Ross thanks for
joining us always always a pleasure
thanks for getting up to talk to us
absolutely there no problem thanks for
having all right that's Ross Tucker NBC
sports network the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]